d'avoir répondu à notre à notre
invitation comme je vous le disais notre
commission traite de sujets dans le
cadre d'une prospective sujet parfois
assez complexe on a traité récemment
l'avenir de l'eau on a traité également
les relations intergénérationnelles
télétravail et les mobilités
robotisation et même la dette publique
vous voyez c'est très large
aujourd'hui nous allons parler d'un
enjeu fondamental celui de l'éducation
il n'est pas nécessaire mes chers
collègues de vous présenter notre invité
il a été auteur de très nombreux
ouvrages le dernier consacré à
l'histoire l'avenir de l'éducation et ce
sont ces deux thèmes qui sont au pluriel
dans le titre de l'ouvrage les chemins
pris par les différents pays du monde
pour former éduquer la jeunesse sont en
effet fortement évolué à travers les
âges mais aussi parce que plusieurs
avenirs sont possibles selon les choix
que nous ferons dans les années qui
viennent à travers votre ouvrage qui
fourmi de référence qui invite à attirer
les leçons de l'histoire vous retracer
avec précision les différentes étapes
qui nous ont menées
jusque aujourd'hui
l'espèce humaine n'est pas la seule à
transmettre des connaissances à travers
les générations mais c'était elle qui a
su organiser et perfectionner son
système de transmission pour organiser
une société de plus en plus complexe et
permettre les progrès techniques et la
marche des idées on peut dire que
l'éducation est consubstantielle à la
civilisation vous montrez que
l'éducation n'a jamais été une question
neutre l'enjeu religieux n'est jamais
très loin souvent restreint les libertés
d'enseigner d'éduquer vous insistez sur
la permanence de méthode de pédagogique
marquée par la violence ou encore la
relégation d'éducation des filles
modèles dont la sortie encore incomplète
et récente vous abordez aussi des
aspects plus contemporains les litigisme
la non-mixité sociale dans l'éducation
le tsunami numérique qui risque de faire
baisser des niveaux d'attention et tout
simplement les capacités des jeunes
enfants ce qui nous inquiète également
vous semblez aussi assez pessimiste sur
la capacité des systèmes éducatifs à
faire face à toutes les attentes
économiques et sociales et vous dessinez
un scénario du pire en pointant du doigt
des échecs récents comme les fondement
rapide en à peine 20 ans d'un système
d'éducation celui de la Suède vous vous
montrez aussi vous montrer également
qu'il existe qu'il existe pardon des
modèles plus positifs comme le modèle
finlandais quel est l'avenir de nos
systèmes éducatifs comment faire pour
mieux apprendre et mieux transmettre
voilà le thème avant de vous céder la
parole pour la présentation de vos
travaux et de vos enseignements pendant
tirer je terminerai mon propos par
quelques interrogations
très concrète qui sont les nôtres pour
le monde mais aussi et surtout pour la
France le niveau baisse le vraiment
faut-il renforcer l'enseignement des
mathématiques comment lutter contre la
facture éducative qui est aussi une
fracture sociale et conduit à une
certaine reproduction sociale de nos
élites comment bien utiliser les outils
numériques doit-on consacrer davantage
de moyens l'éducation mieux payer les
enseignants doit encourager une
éducation généraleiste ou visée
davantage l'acquisition de savoir
pratique peut-on apprendre tout au long
de la vie voilà les nombreuses questions
qui se posent aujourd'hui je vous cède
la parole en présentant bien sûr les
excuses de notre président Mathieu
Darnaud qui est parti en déplacement
avec le président l'archet vous avez la
parole merci Monsieur président merci
madame monsieur les sénateurs c'est un
honneur un petit pour moi d'être des
vôtres
je me suis astreint depuis de longues
années sinon plus de laisser de
comprendre les enjeux de l'avenir à
partir du passé et j'ai écrit un certain
nombre de lire sur l'avenir d'un certain
nombre de secteur
qui couvre à peu près la quasi-totalité
des secteurs d'activité globale et en
effet j'ai voulu
travailler sur un secteur
particulièrement important qui est celui
de l'éducation
donc mon travail a consisté à essayer de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé en matière
d'éducation depuis
très longtemps et de voir si on pouvait
en tirer des lois qui seraient valables
pour pour comprendre l'avenir
et en effet on peut en tirer des lois
que vous verrez dans ce livre pour
peut-être centrer notre conversation sur
ce qui peut vous intéresser le plus
je rappellerai d'abord que
l'école n'a jamais été qu'une partie
très marginale je reconnais un ami
l'école n'a été que toujours qu'une
partie marginale de d'un système
beaucoup plus vaste que le système de la
transmission et c'est dans le cadre de
la transmission qu'il faut qu'il faut
poser le problème de l'éducation
la transmission qui se fait depuis
l'aube des temps par la famille le lieu
de travail l'environnement
les églises et très marginalement par
l'école qui ne concerne qu'une toute
petite partie de la population
qui souvent est d'ailleurs entièrement
au service évidemment du pouvoir et qui
ne se libère de ces contraintes qui ne
devient une école qui apprend à tous que
dans certaines consistes considérations
particulières en particulier
quand le protestantisme déclenche la
nécessité de savoir lire et écrire pour
tout le monde mais ça va aller agréer
pour savoir lire les écritures pas pour
savoir lire écrire pour se libérer de la
contrainte religieuse et ce n'est que
dans cette succession que d'abord au
Pays-Bas puis en Suède puis
aux États-Unis puis très brièvement en
France on a une école qui se veut une
école universelle pour tous etc
avec quand même une obsession des
options permanentes comme vous l'avez
dit monsieur le Président pas de fille
l'obsession de la
de la reproduction sociale
avec même parfois dire de façon
explicite il faut surtout pas apprendre
ce que les gens n'ont pas besoin de
savoir
pour en arriver à aujourd'hui
un système à une situation mondiale et
en particulier française qui est
caractérisée par
des avancées qui peuvent sembler
considérables personne ne savait lire en
1900 presque tout le monde sait lire
aujourd'hui donc ça peut paraître un
succès qui annonce des avenir un avenir
radieux mais c'est loin d'être le cas
parce que nous sommes dans une situation
où il y a un extraordinaire
concentration non seulement des
richesses mais des savoirs
une extraordinaire concentration des
moyens éducatifs pour les élites
absolument partout que ça soit aux
États-Unis que ce soit en
Grande-Bretagne que ce soit en France
avec quelques exceptions dont je
parlerai tout à l'heure
et en France en particulier où le
réquisitoire est terrible puisque notre
système éducatif est de plus en plus
illégal beaucoup plus inégale qu'il
n'était il y a 40 ans
il est beaucoup plus difficile
aujourd'hui à un enfant de milieu
défavorisé d'arriver dans une grande
école et nous avons un bon juge de paix
qui est une institution internationale
remarquable qui est une des meilleures
ont tous et l'OCDE qui fait vraiment un
travail de comparaison internationale
dans ce domaine comme dans beaucoup
d'autres tout à fait remarquable et une
en ressortent partout dans le monde les
inégalités scolaires sont en train de
s'aggraver avec quelque chose qui le
masque un peu c'est à dire qu'il y a à
la fois une amélioration des systèmes
scolaires pour les élites et une
amélioration des systèmes scolaires pour
les classes moyennes supérieures
qui marche que le fait que en dessous
c'est c'est beaucoup moins bien
avec aussi
[Musique]
une double tendance alors d'abord sur le
constat d'aujourd'hui et puis ensuite
les tendances d'avenir sur le constat
d'aujourd'hui
quand on regarde les résultats scolaires
il y a deux bons systèmes il y a le
système finlandais vous avez cité je
pourrais dire un peu de détails qui nous
concerne particulièrement il a un
système coréen du Sud le système coréen
du Sud qui est l'héritier du système du
vieux système chinois
qui a introduit les concours il y a 3000
ans et d'ailleurs c'est fascinant de
voir que les concours ne sont arrivés en
Europe que par les jésuites qui ont été
en visite en Chine et qui ont ramené les
concours en Europe au 17ème 18e siècle
le système Coraline marche très bien
mais c'est un système fondé sur la
compétition permanente à partir de l'âge
de 2 ans
l'obligation de prendre des cours en
complémentaire une tension alors
jusqu'au suicide d'une façon très forte
qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs dans d'autres
sociétés la société chinoise en
particulier pour l'élite pas pour le
peuple ce que c'est une société
extrêmement centralisée qu'on retrouve
retrouver jusqu'à longtemps dans la
société singapourienne qui était
longtemps considéré comme le meilleur
système éducatif mondial j'y reviendrai
peut-être
et à l'inverse on a un système
complètement différent qui est le
système finlandais
qui est l'héritier de du système
hollandais du XVIIe siècle de beaucoup
de systèmes qui ont évolué mais qui ont
culminé aujourd'hui dans le système
finlandais qui a le système radicalement
différent puisque c'est un système où il
y a pas de notation jusqu'à 14 ans
il y a que du travail de groupe il y a
14 élèves par classe
les professeurs et statut social et une
rémunération égale à celle des moyennes
des avocats et des médecins
les professeurs ne sont pas notés pas
inspectés
et on ne fait que du travail collectif
de projet avec un programme général mais
dans lequel les professeurs peuvent
puiser à tout effondré sur la confiance
et le résultat est exceptionnel
évidemment il consacre beaucoup de
moyens évidemment la démographie n'est
pas la même que la nôtre en particulier
le nombre
mais c'est certainement le meilleur de
l'année d'une certaine façon on peut
dire d'une façon un peu polémique que la
France a pris le meilleur le pire des
deux systèmes
le laxisme finlandais et
la compétition
coréenne c'est intéressant de regarder
le modèle singapourien parce que
Singapour qui est une toute petite ville
qui se fait toujours à la pointe du
progrès à très longtemps été
[Musique]
dans le modèle coréen et mieux que les
Coréens ils ont même inventé des
méthodes mathématiques de d'enseignement
du mathématiques qui sont aujourd'hui
mondialement utilisés en France
mais depuis deux ans ils ont fait un
virage à 180 degrés ils sont partis sur
le modèle finlandais donc il faut
regarder ce modèle comme à l'heure où
nous parlons nous façon photographique
comme le meilleur modèle si on regarde
devant nous j'ai
identifié mais je vais évidemment parler
d'une façon caricaturale parce que
l'objet c'est converser puis ça sent pas
je dans ce livre il faut détailler ce
que je suis en train de dire
il y a deux tendances très négatives à
l'échelle mondiale une première tendance
très négative qui est la tendance
démographique qui dans la plupart enfin
dans les pays du monde où la démographie
est croissante va entraîner presque
inévitablement
ce que j'appelle une dictature de
dictature de l'ignorance en Afrique en
Inde au Mexique au Brésil même en Chine
vous le savez entre 60 et 100 élèves par
classe avec des enseignants qui sont pas
du tout au niveau
donc c'est un éducation est une
mascarade un mythe ce n'est pas vrai on
enseigne pas
et quand on pense que comme vous le
savez la démographie indienne mexicaine
ou africaine va continuer à être
explosive on y arrivera pas
sauf à consacrer des moyens que dont on
ne doit pas d'huile vont venir donc on
se prépare un avenir africain indien etc
d'ignorance qui sera remplacée soit par
rien soit par
l'exclusion des filles pour commencer
soit un enseignement religieux qui a
déjà commencé très largement à prendre
la place
et qui d'ailleurs le fait d'une façon
très brutale comme on le voit en
particulier dans certaines régions de
l'Inde et au Nigeria où c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très très systématique
donc là on a une bombe à retardement de
l'ignorance
qui est extrêmement général la deuxième
barbarie cette première c'est la
barbarie de l'ignorance la deuxième
c'est la barbarie technologique
qui et je reviendrai sur les aspects
très positifs de la technologie tout à
l'heure et d'entrer d'entraîner dans les
autres pays surtout un
discrédit de l'ancien éducatif les
élèves savent mieux par ce qu'ils
apprennent sur les réseaux sociaux ou
ailleurs
donc ça crée un discrédit de l'école
ensuite comme vous l'avez dit
ça crée un déficit d'attention qui n'est
pas seulement qui n'est pas spécialement
lié au fait que la tension est plus
courte en effet elle est plus courte
mais qu'il y ait au fait surtout
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une invasion très
jeune des esprits par les jeux vidéo et
par tout cela qui fait que aujourd'hui
et dans certaines régions du monde en
particulier au Canada en Grande-Bretagne
et en France aussi mais dans son corps
moins forte en France le temps occupé
par les jeux vidéo
atteint pas tout à fait mais presque le
temps consacré à l'école on passe des
enfants passe plus de temps devant les
jeux vidéo et les réseaux sociaux
particuliers Tik Tok mais pas seulement
Tik Tok que que à l'école
donc voilà on a là un basculement de
système qui est évidemment
extraordinairement destructif du
processus éducatif si on ajoute à chaque
ça crée un processus de solitude de de
refus de la vie collective on a la
risque énorme de voir
non seulement les écoles discréditées
par le fait que on y va on y va d'une
façon contraindé on y apprend plus ce
qu'on apprend ailleurs mais aussi
détournement de la capacité
d'apprentissage sur des choses futiles
et sans intérêt
en fait le vrai scénario du pire c'est
un mélange des deux c'est à dire un
mélange d'ignorance est utilisation des
réseaux sociaux où on aura les réseaux
sociaux qui remplaceront les les
écoles et
où on peut s'attendre à ce qu'il y ait
une sorte
comme dans le système proprement
économique une énorme concentration des
richesses
du capital intellectuel dans les milieux
qui seront maintenir l'école et le
l'apprentissage au détruments d'une
population qui n'aura plus accès à grand
chose
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire par
rapport à ça je crois que le mieux que
je puisse faire si vous voulez les 20
propositions que je fais pour la France
puisque à la fin je fais la proposition
pour le monde
20 propositions pour la France et 20
propositions pour chacun d'entre nous
alors je vous lis les 20 propositions
pour la France
qui je pense pas vous intéresser
premièrement scolarisé tous les enfants
dès l'âge de 2 ans
deuxièmement doublé autant aussi
rapidement qu'il est possible la dépense
publique d'éducation par élève en
particulier dans le primaire dans la
perspective de ce que j'appelle les
colibri parce que je pense qu'il faut
aller vers une école
qui soit pardon je fais une parenthèse
j'ai constaté que le processus
d'apprentissage ressemble beaucoup au
processus de travail
quand on travaillait dans un atelier aux
champs l'école quand elle existait
c'était un prof qui enseignait à chaque
élève séparément il y avait pas de
classe au sens propre quand on est passé
au travail à la chaîne l'école est
passée au travail à la chaîne c'est à
dire qu'on met les élèves par classe et
ils avancent dans la chaîne
d'année en année exactement comme dans
le travail je pense que l'école de
demain ce sera comme le travail
l'école sera un mélange
d'école à l'école décolle à la maison et
où on aura plusieurs acteurs qui vont
jouer un rôle dans l'apprentissage qui
seront l'école la famille
le périscolaire qui va jouer un rôle
considérable et évidemment les
technologies donc c'est des ces quatre
acteurs pour moi ce que j'appelle
l'école hybrides on aura plus aller à
l'école comme on va au travail
maintenant en faisant du travail à
distance que deux trois jours par
semaine le reste étant dans le
périscolaire dans la famille ou tout
seul c'est ça que j'appelle les colibris
troisièmement imposer en France un
minimum de 20% et un maximum de 30 %
d'élèves
issus de famille défavorisées dans tout
établissement scolaire non seulement
publique et privé ça c'est fondamental
on pourra pas rattraper
notre retard d'égalité scolaire si on ne
fait pas ça et c'est très difficile
réduire massivement le nombre d'élèves
par classe
au moins dans le primaire
décentralisé l'enseignement primaire et
secondaire au niveau des territoires
donner une plus grande autonomie aux
établissements ce qui est pas la même
chose que le décentralisation du système
pour établir un projet avec la
communauté éducative et périscolaire
imposé au moins une heure de sport à
tous les niveaux d'études
former tous les élèves et tous les
enseignants à la laïcité aux valeurs de
la République
remplacer les redoublements par des
positifs de rattrapage en fin d'année
installer dans les quartiers
prioritaires des classes préparatoires
au concours de l'enseignement et des
départements universitaires des grandes
université nationales ce que c'est faux
ce que font certaines villes d'ailleurs
bâtir des établissements d'enseignement
adaptés à ces nouveaux besoins ce qui
fait totalement l'architecture des
écoles qu'il faut transformer
je ne sais pas si je l'ai dit quelque
part ou si je veux dire plus loin
interdire les écrans jusqu'à l'âge de 6
ans
enseignant enseigner dès l'âge de 4 ans
la philosophie et les enjeux de la
survie de la planète
ouvrir un mi au moins un million de
contrats d'apprentissage dans les
métiers dans les métiers de la
transition écologique
former plus encore qu'aujourd'hui les
enseignants pratiques pédagogiques
valorisant l'effort plus que la sanction
prolonger l'aide sociale à l'enfance
jusqu'à 23 ans
développer la formation continue sans
limitage parce qu'en effet une des
choses qu'on constate évidemment c'est
que nous sommes devant les premières
générations
qui sortent de l'école sans savoir les
métiers qui vont faire et qui ne feront
pas les mêmes métiers et dans les
métiers n'existent pas alors qu'avant
l'enseigner des métiers qui existent et
c'est plus le cas
revaloriser financièrement la profession
d'enseignants
promouvoir l'enseignement de la raison
de la vérité de la laïcité de la science
à tous les niveaux de la société
voilà en gros on va mesures ce que je
crois important pour la France
c'est des réformes très fortes qui est
supposent des moyens financiers très
importants mais je pense qu'on s'en
sortira pas sans sans cela et
nous avons les moyens de le faire à
condition de regarder le bon modèle le
modèle finlandais de regarder ce qui
vient et d'utiliser les technologies de
façon positive car elles ne sont pas
négatives on peut constater en effet que
même si moi-même j'en ai été surpris
ce qu'on retient devant un écran
et le meilleur qualité est plus durable
que ce qu'on retient devant un prof
toutes les expériences qui ont été
faites jusqu'à présent le montre
si on utilise des bonnes techniques
d'enseignement devant l'écran ça peut
être extrêmement efficace
je prendrai juste un exemple qui m'a qui
me fascine en ce moment qui est très
intéressant Tik Tok est considéré comme
le diable absolu il l'est pour beaucoup
et je l'ai dit tout à l'heure mais on
voit apparaître tant aux États-Unis
aussi en France un
usage pédagogique de Tik Tok et de
technique voisine qui est le suivant
les élèves de
Première août terminale
qui ont bien appris un théorème le
mettre en ligne dans une vidéo deux
minutes 30 ou une minute trente
et aux États-Unis et ça vient maintenant
en France certains influenceurs de ce
genre sont un pédagogue qui enseigne à
leur père
ont jusqu'à 10 à 12 millions de de gens
qui suivent leur enseignement et on a
maintenant
pratiquement couvert en matière de
partie toc ou par des techniques
voisines la totalité du programme de en
France de première et de terminale
où ce sont les élèves qui enseignent
leur camarades
donc on voit l'enseignement coopératif
l'enseignement de terre les nouvelles
méthodes je donne d'autres exemples de
d'expérience pédagogiques qui marchent
bien
jeunes professeur de philo que je suis
depuis des années qui est à Drancy qui
s'appelle Jérémy fontagnieu qui a dansé
l'ancienne la philo il s'est mis comme
objectif d'avoir
100% de mention très bien au bac dans sa
classe
il est parvenu avec en particulier une
technique très simple il envoie tous les
soirs un sms personnalisé à chaque
parent
au début les parents disaient c'est pas
le sujet etc
et ça marche son expérience maintenant
très développée plus une centaine
d'enseignants qui font ça c'est-à-dire
un film qui est fait sur lui en ce
moment ce qui est dit qu'il y a beaucoup
d'expérience et dans lequel la
communauté éducative parent enseignant
nouvelle technologie périscolaire va
jouer un rôle très important je citer
ces deux exemples pour montrer que les
technologies peuvent être extrêmement
utile lorsqu'on les encadre d'une façon
efficace
voilà
il y aurait beaucoup d'autres choses à
dire monsieur
vous avez été très synthétique puisque
nous avons convenu avec jaquette Attali
que cette réunion durait une heure pile
puisque nous avons tous des engagements
je vous laisse la parole sans plus
tarder ce qui souhaitent poser des
questions
à notre invité
tu te présentes
et grand fan de ce que vous faites
parce que vous posiez la question au
président juste au début de cette
réunion
cette délégation la prospective
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait mais écoutez vous
devriez être invité permanent
puisque votre ouvrage Une brève histoire
de l'avenir c'est exactement ce que nous
essayons de faire je voudrais savoir si
vous pouvez expliciter un petit peu plus
le rapport qui me paraît extrêmement en
tout cas d'actualité entre l'éducation
et la religion parce que je sais que
c'est un
quand on regarde l'histoire qui est
assez intéressante à comprendre
il y a eu plusieurs systèmes d'éducation
qui ont été pour l'essentiel fondé sur
enseigner ce qui est utile au prince ou
aux hommes de pouvoir et évidemment il y
a eu des très longtemps des écoles qui
enseignaient pour devenir prêtre ou en
tout ou pour enseigner la religion
quelle que soit la religion
aux dirigeants de façon à ce que le
dirigeants soient
conforme aux exigences de l'église du
temps il y a eu un cas particulier très
particulier qui était ce qui s'est passé
avec le peuple juif qui lui a demandé
vers peut-être vers 800 avant notre ère
mais certainement 700 avant notre ère
tout le monde doit savoir lire et écrire
de façon à lire les textes alors ça
parle plus ou moins bien marché et bien
pas très bien mais il y a eu cette
constante de tout le monde doit savoir
lire écrire mais lire d'une façon
religieuse quand apparaît le
christianisme l'église elle a assez vite
assez vite au quatrième siècle
l'obsession de prendre de pouvoir sur
l'école
et dans la chrétienté on voit toutes les
écoles qui s'étaient développées dans le
monde romain
être pris progressivement d'une façon
très systématique par l'Église
pour que l'Église enseigne au clair
c'est à dire à ceux qui vont être les
acteurs de la vers religieuse et
accessoirement à tous ceux qui tournent
autour du pouvoir pour qu'ils aient
aussi une teinture de religibilité et
cette prise du pouvoir dans le monde
européen
par l'Église va durer
très longtemps puisque on va enseignant
latin jusqu'au 17e siècle etc
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est le
monde protestant qui va faire sauter un
peu cela en faisant que ça soit l'école
puisse enseigner à tout le monde à lire
écrit parce que dans les écoles telles
que le catholicisme développé il fallait
apprendre par cœur pas besoin de savoir
lire mais pas besoin on apprenait pas à
lire parce qu'il fallait qu'on croyait
ce que l'Église disait donc il fallait
apprendre par cœur ce que les prêtres
disaient et
c'est le protestantisme qui va faire un
peu changer ça d'abord pour installer
une connaissance du texte direct et très
progressivement aller au-delà de la
connaissance du texte
mais dans la société française comme
dans les sociétés dans d'autres sociétés
le pouvoir du religieux est extrait
rester extraordinairement puissant dans
l'école il y a eu une tentative de
réaction très efficace de forme
extrêmement efficace
contre le protestantisme qui a été monté
par les Jésuites à ce moment-là montée
en réaction très vite d'ailleurs la
réaction protestantisme un système
scolaire très sophistiqué qui a été
vraiment pensé avec pendant de longues
années je raconte ça dans le livre avec
la réflexion sur les meilleures méthodes
pédagogiques qui étaient
extraordinairement en avance sur leur
temps
qui ont construit il y a une sorte de
doctrine pédagogique tout à fait
exceptionnelle et qui a développé une
volonté d'enseigner non seulement aux
futurs acteurs de l'église mais au futur
acteurs de l'état de l'élite tout ce
qu'il fallait savoir
et cette
dualité élite religieux à continuer très
longtemps
elle a continué différemment dans le
monde protestant et dans le monde
catholique et dans le monde catholique à
la continuité très particulièrement en
France avec
mis à part la parenthèse forrique et
utopique de 1789 à 1796 où on a eu
formidable tentative qui n'ont jamais
marché de d'une école laïque générale
mais qui était incroyablement qui avait
des siècles d'avance fascinant à suivre
ensuite on est retombé des Napoléon tout
de suite sur l'église et le pouvoir sont
connivence pour maintenir la société et
c'est très lentement comme vous savez à
la fin du 19e que
en France on est on a tenté de sortir de
ça et définir ce concept très français
très particulier très spécifique de la
laïcité sachant que partout ailleurs on
a plutôt
installé c'est à mon avis extrêmement
dangereux une sorte d'indifférence
chacun apprend ce qu'il veut des écoles
font ce qu'elle veut la religion un peu
être là si elle veut c'est pas grave
c'est pas gênant
on voit ça dans le monde de clochasson
dans le monde protestant hollandais en
loi évidemment dans toute une autre
partie du monde dans l'Islam ça reste
une maîtrise très forte de l'Islam sur
le l'enseignement avec les conséquences
qu'on connaît c'est-à-dire que dans ces
sociétés on sait pas lire on sait pas
écrire on sait pas on sait rien d'autre
que le Coran est donc on le voit dans
les conséquences sur le niveau scolaire
le niveau de recherche scientifique la
publication enfin c'est l'islam à partir
du 12e alors que l'islam au début
était très en avance puisque l'islam
était fondé sur la l'apologie de la
science mais c'est au 12e siècle qui
sont choisis de se fermer
et donc il y a une tyrannie du religieux
qui est en train de revenir
dans l'Islam d'une façon très forte
qui
n'a jamais quitté la société américaine
puisque société américaine reste fondé
sur une juxtaposition de de communauté
qui chacun mène leur vie comme elle
l'entend y compris d'un point de vue
éducatif et la France est un est un cas
très particulier
où on a inventé ce concept de laïcité et
on tente de le maintenir contre moi
vents et marais sachant que la tendance
naturelle et
débrouillez-vous faites ce que vous
voulez et donc d'une juxtaposition de
communauté qui à mon avis conduira la
catastrophe les pays d'ici engagent
parce que si vous avez vu que sa
position de communauté vous finirez par
avoir
des conflits entre elles et vous n'aurez
plus de fabrique sociale ne la
collectivité au point même qu'on ira ce
qui arrive déjà en Grande-Bretagne ou
dans au Canada enseigné dans dans les
langues de chacun pas seulement dans les
Landes nationales et de voir la société
seront
donc le modèle français est très unique
on connaît ces difficultés de mise en
oeuvre mais je crois qu'il faut vraiment
tenir mordicus là dessus parce que c'est
la clé de la nation
merci alors nos collègues de questions
on va les regrouper vas-y tu te
présentes oui Bernard fieler donc
sénateur du Rhône était rencontré
récemment moi vous dites que on passe
que que les enfants passent plus de
temps finalement sur les réseaux sociaux
et au même moment donc ça demande quand
même une concentration et du temps et on
nous dit que le temps scolaire peut pas
être on a passé à le voir se réduire
parce qu'on dit autrement on a des
pédagogues qui même des neurosciences
qui nous disent qu'il faut qu'on peut
pas
développer plus de temps à l'école or il
semble quand même que que la liberté
qu'on a rendu aux élèves et quand on les
renvoie même pas seulement dans les
familles mais dans la rue et bien au
contraire ils se disperse et qu'ils
apprennent pas donc est-ce que vous
pensez que le temps scolaire ou le temps
passé à l'école devrait être plus long
et que
des raisons scientifiques
sénateurs
merci pour tout ce que vous écrivez et
ce que vous faites depuis longtemps
je ne doute pas que vous échangiez sur
ces questions avec les acteurs actuels
du monde de l'éducation et pouvez-vous
nous éclairer sur le ressenti qui est le
vôtre sur le diagnostic partagé mais sur
la réception qui est la leur devant par
exemple les propositions que vous faites
pour faire en sorte que il y ait quand
même de l'espoir qui soit partagé par
tous les acteurs et quels sont selon
vous la place et la degré de motivation
de ces acteurs du monde de l'éducation
aujourd'hui face aux défis que vous nous
exposez
merci
j'aurais mis juste que vous développiez
un petit peu le ce que vous avez dit sur
l'extrême concentration des richesses et
du savoir en disant que les inégalités
scolaires c'est des considérablement
aggravés depuis 30 ans ça m'interpelle
beaucoup parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'au contraire on a beaucoup plus accès
au savoir et pour un peu qu'on sache
utiliser les réseaux autrefois un enfant
je dis anecdotiquement devait aller dans
l'Encyclopédie Universalis pour aller
chercher les informations aujourd'hui il
peut cliquer sur Internet Wikipédia tout
ça avoir accès à l'information donc ça
semble un peu contradictoire avec ce
qu'on imagine j'aurais aimé que vous
nous développiez un tout petit peu plus
cet aspect merci merci et puis
[Musique]
il me semble que en tout cas si on se
place dans le contexte français mais
dans celui de plusieurs pays européens
le besoin d'assurer en particulier une
meilleure cohésion scolaire et
redressement des inégalités naturelles
suppose d'une part
une application des parents
qui aujourd'hui
j'ai l'impression ne progresse pas
et que donc on a
le service public la mission
d'enseignement à un problème de relais
de ce côté-là
donc je sais pas si tu regardes s'il y
avait des expériences qui étaient parce
que on voit bien
des sensibilités ou des attitudes
collectives qui sont très différentes
dans les communautés c'est vrai aussi
bien aux États-Unis qu'en France
il y a des contrastes quand même
très substantiel quant à
l'investissement
proscolaire de certaines catégories ou
certaines origines
il me semble que
dans le contexte des pays riches
avancés mais être assez inégaux comme
les sociétés européennes
il y a vraiment un axe politique qu'il
faut
qu'il faut rendre efficace je sais pas
si on voit beaucoup d'expérience qui
montre ça puis deuxième la deuxième
préoccupation que je vois si on veut
justement faire progresser à la fois la
la pluridisciplinarité et le
travail collectif c'est est-ce que le
schéma très disciplinaire de notre
formation
d'enseignants étonnable or on voit bien
je ne sais plus à quel moment on a fait
cette tentative de proposer je crois de
valoriser
pour les profs de collège
d'enseigner deux disciplines et rien que
ça provoqué à la française une réaction
extrêmement hostile chacun
derrière les murs de son champ
disciplinaire
est-ce qu'on est très particulier de ce
côté là est-ce que d'autres pays ont
mieux réussi cette capacité
interdisciplinaire pour les enseignants
du secondaire en particulier
si
je vais essayer de répondre à
quelques-unes des questions
d'avoir sur les inégalités tous les
chiffres sont frappants vous trouverez
dans le lit mais le
les
je rappelle quelques chiffres pour la
France
plus de la moitié des étudiants doivent
travailler moins un moment de leurs
études en France 50% des étudiants de la
grandes écoles ont des parents cadres de
professions supérieures qui représentent
que 17% de la population active
65 % des enfants de cadres son diplômé
de l'enseignement supérieur contre 30%
des enfants d'ouvriers d'employés vous
continuez la liste très longtemps et
avec une aggravation de ces chiffres
depuis 30 ans qui est certaine
le soleil a publié des chiffres
là-dessus très très fort et c'est vrai
dans tous les pays aux États-Unis c'est
pareil avec une grande concentration et
avec en effet la rejoindre la question
d'aller un peu certaines communautés qui
ont
un encadrement familial extrêmement fort
et capacité de réussite très forte on
l'a vu avec essentiellement
des deux communautés qui ont été très
exclu de l'université parce que
justement craignait beaucoup qu'ils
avancent trop vite qui était là
communauté juive où il y a eu je vous
raconte pression très forte et
université américaine pour pas les
recevoir parce que si on les admettaient
ils prenaient toutes les places et
maintenant avec la communauté asiatique
qui qu'elle soit étrangères ou
américaine un taux de réussite
extraordinaire parce que il y a une
pression familiale
une fonction de la famille qui reste
absolument absolument essentiel quand la
famille est là pour ça que je parle des
quatre acteurs la famille l'école
le périscolaire
et l'enfant lui-même avec les réseaux
c'est quatre acteurs qu'il faut mettre
en mouvement et la famille là où elle
existe et elle existe surtout dans
certaines communautés on peut jouer un
rôle important évidemment quand la
famille joue contre l'école qui arrive
dans certains milieux en particulier
musulmans c'est c'est un autre problème
certains milieux de
orthodoxe de toutes les religions
le temps passé à l'école
alors le temps passé à l'école
il est clair que on pourrait faire mieux
mais plus la durée des vacances
scolaires me paraît dans les très élevés
en France par rapport à d'autres pays
elle pourrait être plus grande mais je
pense que c'est plus dans dans ce qu'on
fait à l'école qu'on a beaucoup à gagner
en particulier tout ce qui est projet
le basculement vers une école de projet
plutôt qu'une école d'enseignement où
chacun reçoit ce qu'il reçoit
individuellement et
vraiment change beaucoup de choses
le fait de de
faire que les élèves travaillent entre
eux et changent énormément de choses
plus encore que le temps
le travail à la maison le travail dans
le périscolaire le fait de faire plus de
sport
le fait de de
d'apprendre à utiliser chez soi les
réseaux sociaux d'une façon intelligente
permet je crois de compenser le fait que
l'école ne doit pas te prendre tout le
temps et je pense je propose au
contraire de passer moins de temps à
l'école si on passe à l'école hybride
c'est-à-dire qu'une partie du temps se
fait en dehors un apprentissage
libéré est-ce que est-ce que les les
pouvoirs publics
français reprennent ses idées le message
que j'ai reçu mais je dois avoir de
quelques confirmations prochaine c'est
que
ils sont très intéressés par tout ça et
ils souhaitent s'engager dans les
directions que je propose mais je n'ai
pas d'autres indications que pour
l'instant très légères et c'est à vous
interroger le ministre
qui va faire un retour très très positif
ainsi que d'autres acteurs mais
ça suppose des révolutions considérables
dernière les écoles et les Chinois je le
rappelle ont interdit les écrans jusqu'à
l'âge de 4 ans aujourd'hui et il limite
d'une façon pénale
l'usage de jeux vidéo 1h30 par semaine
ça existe une intrusion dans la vie des
familles qu'on n'est pas prêt à faire
mais
Tik Tok et chinois mais ils interdisent
l'usage de Tik Tok de Vincent massive un
petit peu comme comme les Anglais je
peux faire un parallèle développer
l'opium en Chine pour ruiner la Chine
sans l'utiliser elle-même si on peut
faire ce parallèle peut-être un peu osé
donc je crois qu'il y a vraiment des
choses tout à fait tout à fait
révolutionnaires à faire je sais pas si
j'ai répondu à tout non
ah oui sur le caractère c'est pour ça
que je parlais tout à l'heure du
des projets c'était il est évident qu'il
faut il reste qu'il faut enseigner
beaucoup de choses qu'on pourrait dire
là-dessus d'abord il faut est-ce qu'il
faut encore enseigner les fondamentaux
lire et écrire
traduire compter a priori non parce que
on a les machines pour lit on a des
machines pour écrire on a des machines
pour compter il y a même aujourd'hui
comme il y a 800 millions d'années en
Afrique semble-t-il potentiellement
des téléphones qui sont en train de se
développer qui non seulement sont des
machines à calculer mais qui lisent les
messages que vous recevez et
traduisent en écrit ce que les messages
que vous dictez donc vous avez plus
besoin de savoir dire ni lire ni écrire
ni compter donc il faut quand même
voilà
vous avez parlé également des métiers
qui n'existent pas et effectivement
c'est déjà posé la question nous dans le
cas de la prospective parce qu'avant on
nous disait il faut une formation
vraiment très spécifique pour
l'évolution des métiers etc et
maintenant on dit il faut de toute chose
généraliste parce que le métier de
demain vous le connaissez pas encore
donc faudra se spécialiser un peu plus
tard pour correspondre à l'emploi qui
qui sera offert comment on peut dans
cette partie là miser sur la formation
de métiers qu'on ne connaît pas encore
c'est là où j'ai donné dans ce livre une
liste des métiers qui vont apparaître
donc il y a des métiers qui n'existent
pas mais on commence à voir des métiers
qui n'existent pas qui vont apparaître
donc on peut déjà commencer à faire
deuxièmement il faut maintenant cesser
de parler de l'école et du travail ça
doit être permanent il n'est pas normal
que la formation permanente ne se passe
pas à l'université il est pas normal que
l'université n'est pas un devoir de
formation permanente de tous ces élèves
normalement ça commence à exister dans
quelques grandes écoles mais normalement
quand une école forme un élève elle
devrait lui garantir qu'elle va
l'accepter de revenir trois semaines ou
un mois par an dans son école pour
pouvoir se former en permanence tout au
long de la vie ça doit être une
assurance tout au long de la sortie de
la distinction formation travail bon ce
qui suppose d'ailleurs de mêler ça avec
la formation professionnelle permanente
information dans les entreprises avec
les écoles d'entreprises parce qu'on
voit c'est très frappant de voir
maintenant des entreprises qui
considèrent que que l'enseignement
supérieur a failli et que c'est à elle
de former donc on voit d'apparaître
c'est ce que ce qui est en train de
faire monsieur Blanquer il a dit
publiquement donc il a été appelé pour
faire ça dans les métiers de la
transition écologique l'université
l'école fait pas ce qu'il faut donc une
grande entreprise française Veolia crée
pas seulement pour elle mais pour la
société française des formations tout au
long de la vie des gens qui vont ça
c'est une
Veolia intelligemment le fait ils ont
raison de le faire ça prouve quand même
qu'un lacune dans le système
d'enseignement ce que ce que font
quelques grandes écoles qui commencent
un peu à le faire mais très très peu ce
que font très bien quelques universités
américaines les grandes universités
américaines font ça remarquablement et
ça leur permet de garder un lien avec
leurs élèves qui d'ailleurs ensuite
quand ils reviennent sont des donateurs
de l'université enfin c'est très c'est
pas du tout désintéressé voilà et ça
fait partie du modèle économique de ces
universités mais là il faut vraiment
faire sauter cette barrière entre
et vous auriez sans doute intérêt à
faire sans toute réflexion sur c'est
quoi les métiers d'après demain
vous en trouverez deux pages de
science-fiction de liste de métiers qui
sont qui sont qui sont en train de venir
il y a beaucoup de choses autour des
neurosciences autour du biomimétisme
autour des nanotechnologies autour de
l'interface homme machine de
l'intelligence artificielle beaucoup de
choses qui qui viennent et qui sont qui
sont qui seront là dans 4-5 ans là c'est
plus difficile à prévoir d'ailleurs la
formation des seniors également si on
veut travailler plus longtemps on va
continuer à les former une dernière
question
que ça c'est capital parce que le
problème c'est que les parents souvent
peuvent pas aider ce sont souvent des
dispositifs qui le méconnent et comment
fait-on pour que dans la sphère privée
aussi un enfant sache au mieux utiliser
les réseaux sociaux est-ce que ça passe
par la transmission de ce savoir au sein
de l'école et la deuxième chose aussi
c'est que vous semble-t-il qu'il y a
également une crise de l'autorité et du
respect autrefois en respectant son
professeur il me semble que c'est de
moins en moins le cas ce qui rentre dans
au-delà de la crise des sables de la
transmission des savoirs aussi dans une
prise de l'éducation au sens globale du
merci beaucoup
une question c'est pour insister un
petit peu j'arrive pas à faire le lien
vous dites qu'il y a une grande
discrimination sociale et que les
enfants devraient rester moins à l'école
et un peu plus apprendre en famille il y
a des familles qui sont pas du tout
étayantes et donc c'est ça qui me choque
c'est pour ça que je
[Musique]
volontariste de l'intégration
extrêmement difficile et tous les
expériences ont montré
que les gens qui viennent de milieu
défavorisés en tout à gagner et que les
gens des milieux favorisés n'ont rien à
y perdre contrairement à ce qu'on croit
quand je regarde le structure urbaine
l'essai du basing
américain si on essaie de le transcrire
même en mettant par la maternelle
ça fait quand même dire que on organise
des transports
des mouvements humains dans des milieux
urbains de plus en plus dysfonctionnel
pour une population de millions
d'enfants tout petits
c'est le prix c'est le prix à payer pour
éviter une société fragmentée ça rentre
quand même assez moyennement dans
l'application des principes de liberté
individuelle
si la liberté individuelle contient
à la
textes qui organisent ça
à la fin devant le Conseil
constitutionnel ça risque de passer
juste quand même
exactement exactement
on n'a pas la liberté de ne pas aller à
l'école
encore les formations dans les villes au
détriment des campagnes alors que la
route est dans les deux sens on pourrait
imaginer aussi des gens
qui m'a beaucoup intéressé qui est le
maire de Meaux qui est aussi président
de Paris et je me trompe pas qui a pas
de mots de
linge quoi Melun
qui a fait venir des départements de
Paris dans sa ville Google
c'est un exemple qui est très
intéressant parce que au lieu de bouger
le tableau du piano il a bougé le
tabouret quoi
si les enfants vous écoutent ils vont
voir que il y a de la place encore pour
les réseaux de façon à traiter de façon
intelligente et vous dites qu'on apprend
mieux par les réseaux enfin je sais pas
ce que je pense ses collègues mais moi
j'ai beaucoup plus de difficultés quand
quand je dis des des messages de mails
que quand j'ai un papier
les choses comme quoi vous voyez que on
peut concilier et vous avez une approche
de l'école hybride qui est un concept
qui est intelligent et qui a nous faire
bien entendu réfléchir toutes et tous en
tout cas merci
on va à l'école moins longtemps dans la
semaine ça permet aussi de développer
l'école
avec moins de moyens c'est vrai aussi
écoutez merci pour ces réflexions et
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation merci